if you're an adult you can do that to
someone else's child because you never
get hit as a kid from others absolutely
from the teacher i got smashed i got my
knuckles wrapped by nuns
they would hit you on the knuckles with
a ruler so did you grow up in strict
catholicism well catholicism is always
strict is it
what well catholicism well i do no but
i'm saying like you could have a
catholic family you went to a catholic
school but but you didn't no did you go
to church on sunday yes we did i did not
go to catholic school i went to
catechism that was catholic instruction
that you went to on sunday before church
but i went to regular public school but
my mother was jewish
not that i really knew that as a child
you didn't know that
no um it's the first scene in my
religious documentary the i interviewed
my mother at the church that we used to
go to why they let us do that that
church was not smart that day
back in 2007 but they let my mother and
my sister and i sit in the church
and have this discussion
a very anti-catholic discussion and i
asked my mother i said
why did i not know this and it's just so
indicative of how when you're a child
whatever is going on
you just accept is normal because you
don't know any better it's why when kids
get abused at that age they very often
don't say anything because you have
nothing to compare it to you don't know
what's wrong that your uncle is touching
you my uncle was not touching me this is
not what happened to me but the fact
that i went to church every sunday with
my father and my sister and my mother
always stayed home it never even
occurred to me to ask why
until i just came up one christmas as i
recall
i was 13
13 and i'm like why don't you go to
church and she said because i'm jewish
i'm like you're jewish
and she said
she said
well i mean culturally you know she i've
never been in a temple she's never been
in a temple did you not know her parents
your grandparents
well she her she did not have a father
she was
my grandmother her mother was a real
ahead of her time flapper in the 20s a
jewish flapper a jewish flapper and she
well flapper i mean whatever it was back
then i think that was the word but she
told me
once that she drove and the men would
yell at her they would yell
from the other car
you know because this was
the way to meet no no it was they were
yelling at her because women shouldn't
be driving at all oh wow
can you imagine a time when it was tough
on women
women's rights were taken away um
some that time is sometimes now thursday
last thursday i mean that's an
exaggeration that's not i always say
let's live in the time we're living in
there's not there's still lots of
things that are wrong with our society
but there's also a lot of faking about
you know we're not it's not 1950 anymore
but let me ask you so you have a sister
are you close to your sister let's not
pretend are you close to your sister
yeah i mean are she married no
in our way we're close you know um we're
very different but
um you know i think we have a great
relationship that you have children
no
no not to my knowledge wow what's in the
mar what was in the mar house that you
guys didn't want to
continue in that cycle of
neighborhood um
well i don't i mean you'll have to ask
her that's i'm not going to answer for
her i i know for me
um
i didn't like
children when i was a child
you didn't like yourself and it's i
didn't like well what do you mean
i mean well we all as children were all
insecure and we all have um
issues with ourselves of course
but i just didn't i wasn't sure i wasn't
a child lover i didn't like cartoons
like for example i didn't like childlike
things i thought it was i thought
cartoons were like childish and i still
think that except for like family guy i
love that one but like generally i don't
like cartoons i would only watch like
film shows like superman three stooges
things that were live action um
i just didn't like children
and i still don't you know i just
they're they're they're
they're dumb
they start off they're not sophisticated
uh they're disgusting when they're
really young i mean it's just snot and
puke and [ __ ] and it's just
you know really old people are like that
again well
it depends on how you treat yourself
that can happen yes
and if it gets to that point i hope
someone just takes me out because yeah i
don't want to like wake up in a pool of
my own gross
but
[Music]
you